Communism works
in very small scales and that's because
a very small scale commune is a is a
ideologically homogeneous group of
people that have all agreed on how they
want to live and what they do and even
then there's still some challenges but
you can't scale it up because I there's
there's one famous commune they have a
hundred open slots if someone leaves
someone can apply to join and they let
you come in everything's shared but it's
still controlled by a committee there's
still people who are hierarchical in
control of it and can choose to let you
in or not
the challenge is when you try scaling up
something like communism utterly fails
because ideology starts to become more
and more disparate As you move away from
the central Hub so I'll explain it this
way if you have a city a cultural center
that has like Broadway for instance
people are sharing ideas they're
producing similar culture and content
you see an emergent phenomenon of
different styles of art emerging but it
all swirls around certain ideas the
further out you get away from that Hub
the less people are a part of that
culture now you're hundreds of miles
away now you're thousands of miles away
and now they don't even speak the same
language you can't have a single system
where those people agree with each other
we're seeing this in the U.S people in
cities view the world one way people
outside of cities view it another way
somebody who's living in in rural
Nebraska is for some reason in an
argument over gun control with someone
who lives in the heart of New York City
where they're completely different
worlds one guy walks outside and he sees
mountains and nothing else or fields of
of corn and he's like wait who who am I
hurting by having an AR-15 then there's
a guy who's in New York City surrounded
shoulder to shoulder with tons of people
everywhere and he's like if someone
fired a gun it would cause chaos and
Mayhem they're not even arguing the same
world and they don't realize it so this
is this is a huge component of the
problem we're facing here in the US
particularly with cities versus rural
areas that seems to be the big split
component long story short my point is
if everybody had a shared ideology
there'd be no problems people would all
just get along and agree oh yeah that's
the thing that's the way it's supposed
to be yeah it's interesting you say that
too because a lot of the uh communist
intellectuals that they like to say like
Peter kropaken for example if I recall
correctly when he was writing his
treatises he was talking about like
communes of like 100 people and like
it's like yeah that could probably work
but when you scale to this level or even
like with the USSR a large reason that
they collapsed was because of the
different ethnicities that they had all
under this one flag
um and I think it can go both ways I
think politics can be Downstream from
culture but I think culture can also be
Downstream from politics like for
example with the USSR I mean that was a
uh an Orthodox Christian country and you
had the Bolsheviks come in and they
forced in communism and they killed the
Tsar
um and they they implemented that to a
population that didn't want it you mean
Russia was Christian and then the
Bolsheviks came in and turned it into
the Soviet Union yeah yeah and then uh
or even like with gay marriage for
example California arguably the most
liberal state in the country they shot
that down in I think 2008 as a state
right seven years later Barack Obama you
know takes credit for the Supreme Court
legislating from the bench saying this
is now what we're doing and now seven
years later you look at where we are now
so there is this sort of assumption from
the population which I understand that
sort of the the government or the laws
of the society are generally going to
reflect its morality or its sentiment
and so when people saw the government
doing that you know the White House lit
up in the rainbow flag I think it did
kind of influence the culture like oh
this is what we're doing this is what
normal people think and that sort of
opened up the floodgates for everything
that we're seeing now and this is
exactly what honest leftists have
criticized me for it's very fascinating
typically they just lie and they'll lie
about something because they're trying
to convince people who aren't initiated
into politics to join their side but I
had someone I love this they said the
reason they hate me said this on
Facebook was that I shatter consensus
reality
and I was like well thank you thank you
for being honest they want consensus
reality that's it they don't care what's
true they care about what is perceived
as true so that everybody marches in
lockstep we are deviants we are outside
of that and we are pulling people from
it that threatens their structure they
want superficial uh you know diversity
not diversity of thought which is again
something that is very dangerous and
something that is regressive and is
actually going to be hurting them in the
long run especially when it comes to
building any kind of society but to add
to your earlier point there I do believe
that the solution is going to be
Community oriented people coming
together setting up homeschool pods
setting up uh you know protections uh
setting up Community watches uh being
able to learn to defend themselves being
able to to create farms and and to share
food and to share resources with people
I believe that right there is going to
be a lot better that right there is a
true form of Anarchy that I believe
could be practiced should be practiced
and it all it takes is you guys talking
to your neighbors and doing the right
thing and moving away from the state
because any kind of larger state that is
based on forcing people to share an
ideology is to me a very dangerous state
it's tough I wish there were easier
answers to all of this you know we have
so many people who say like hey we just
want to live in peace we want to live in
peace but um it's funny because we do we
really do but then you see that some
ideologies just don't get along like in
the UK in um I can't remember the name
of the area there was a school doing
LGBT curriculum and Muslims came out to
protest it a member of the LGBT
community comes out and says we're doing
this for you and they're like how dare
you how dare you you you claim that and
it's interesting because I've even seen
these paintings where it shows a woman
in hijab but it's a rainbow and I'm like
in the real world there's there they
really really are angry about this like
in Dearborn Michigan where they're going
to this meeting saying do not vote
Democrat because they are attacking
Muslim values
these are these are religious
conservatives but for some reason
there's an attempt by the left to act
like they're part of the same Community
they don't get along I I want everybody
to live peacefully tolerance does not
mean acceptance it means you know you do
your thing I'll do mine let's try not to
infringe upon each other but then the
problem emerges where when these
communities start butting up against
each other and one one Community says we
find it abhorrent to do this Behavior
the other community says if you repress
X Behavior you are a bigot and a tyrant
well now you've got a potential for
conflict and there's no simple solution
like the law it doesn't change how
people feel about things so there's no
simple solution yeah if I if either
people have shared values or agree to
live under an umbrella of certain values
or you will start seeing conflict and
what we have for the past 10 or 20 years
this this push for multiculturalism
it's it's it's proposed as here's the
American umbrella of the Constitution
underneath it different cultures can
coexist peacefully what it's become is
the umbrella of American culture has
been destroyed and accused of being
monstrous and now you have different
cultures all existing at the same level
and targeting each other and that's just
a recipe for disaster it's a religion of
wokeness that is destroying the fabric
of society yeah and so much of uh you
know it's often very popular for
conservatives to point out that the
Liberals were the ones who wanted free
speech back in the day but now they're
the tyrants and it's like well it's
actually been pretty consistent insofar
as they didn't have a seat at the table
because this was a moral country and
then we gave them a seat at the table
and then they started promoting the
worst things ever kicking conservatives
out of the institutions and now they're
like okay we're happy we don't want to
give you guys free speech so we saw what
uh happened when you grant you know
tolerance and things like that to people
who are fundamentally like trying to
destroy your whole country and now like
it's not enough for us to just say okay
we'll be tolerant you know private
individual in the privacy of your own
home because we were tolerant and then
you see when people are embodying
identities they're that are
fundamentally disordered whether it's
the body positivity movement or LGBT
stuff they still feel a sense of like
incongruence or guilt with what they're
doing and so then they project that to
society where you have grotesquely obese
people who are saying the reason I feel
bad about the way I look is because of
society giving me dirty looks or people
who are maybe experiencing a gender
dysphoria will say the reason I am
unhappy is because of this a people like
Tim Poole are being so mean to me right
now but they don't care about what you
think on virtually any other issue but
the one that's most important their
whole identity that's the one that all
of a sudden they value your opinion so
strongly it's a cult you know funny
thing happened to me today I got a phone
call from some like leftist guy yelling
at me and it was funny so what happened
was I was ordering Starbucks I know I'm
not a big fan of Starbucks but somebody
uh I think you wanted Starbucks is that
what happened this these are allegations
but uh you know corporatists will
Communists showing the cup on screen
it's strategic the Strategic cut
placement you know look I'll say it I
don't like them as a corporation but
they consistently do better and it by
bothers me that's the case but anyway I
digress I was ordering and so it was a
big order because it was for the office
it was for everybody and I get a phone
call and so I'm like the only I never
answer my phone ever but this time I was
like they're probably calling me saying
like yo what are you you're nuts you're
ordering too much but it was actually
some guy just yelling at me and he was
like why are you saying these things and
then I actually started talking to him
and I was like the craziest thing was
you know I don't approach these
conversations albeit this one was by
accident but I love a good conversation
with anybody I don't care who they are
especially someone on the left and and
very quickly I was like the things you
think I did aren't true the thing
someone told you I said are not what I
actually said you made a mistake and I
don't blame you for that here's what I
actually said and then the dude was like
okay well uh uh yeah he still wanted to
be mad at me because of this cult
element to it but I was like my guy
I want LGBT people to be safe and to
have their clubs and to celebrate and to
drink and and be merry what I don't want
is for child abusers to pretend that
they're part of what is going on with
people enjoying a drink in their own
private adult lives to then use you as a
shield that's what I called out and if
anyone said otherwise then they're not
really listening to what I'm saying and
we shouldn't be mad at each other we
should figure out how to work together
that's interesting conversation
ultimately it ended with uh two two
simple words that everybody knows and
you have to drink and if I say it
because the end result was like the
dudes attitude was basically like
um
no no compromise and then I was like
okay well like if this is the case then
Civil War is going to happen and we and
then he was like okay and then he hung
up and he was like I'll tell everyone
you said that I assume he was recording
it but I'm like yeah go for it man like
we want there to be no violence we want
people just to be like okay like you
know we solve this with like a game of
soccer or something
unfortunately
if people view the world so differently
it's like we had this golden age for so
long in this country
I say for so long but maybe for like 10
or 20 years where we really didn't see
the the the the conflict that the rest
of the world sees that we fail to
realize how this stuff
comes to fruition
I remember watching this old show I
can't remember what it was I was very
very little so probably something in a
religious class where it was like a
Christian being approached by a
different religious person it was a
cartoon or something and they said
renounce your God and the man said never
I won't do it and they said then so be
it and they like started beating him or
something and I thought that was crazy
and I was like what just say yes so that
like they don't beat you and kill you
and take you from your family and then
let them leave and then you can go back
to believe whatever you want and it's
only now as an adult I realize why
people actually feel the way they do
about things like that and why they
would never back down because ideology
is strong with people who have
determined they are good there's good
people there's evil people there's those
that seek to harm and do and be
destructive and they will never submit
to it and I'm like okay now I get War
yeah the uh the midterms you know
fortification aside are really great
evidence of that like people are very
willing to accept a lower material
standard of living if it means they get
to think to themselves that people like
us are like seething and miserable and
things like that they're willing to
actually do that and any mainstream
Democrat politician can come out and say
look I'm not a socialist look I'm not a
communist and they will still be in the
club but none of them would dare say
look I'm not in favor of all this
transgender stuff I'm not in favor of
all this worship of diversity equity and
inclusion I'm not in favor of all this
Mass immigration they would get exiled
for that so in effect that is actually
what the Democrat Party what leftism is
it is the diversity equity and inclusion
worship it is the transgenderism it is
all of that other stuff the mass
migration the open borders that is like
what it is in effect because you cannot
be in that party and denounce things
like that they will kick you out for
that so this is the problem like if that
is the hill that they're willing to die
on how are we supposed to reconcile that
as people who more or less just want to
be left alone there's a saying they
often say the old world is dying and the
new world struggles to be born and I'm
like I agree with that you know their
their their view of it is it's a good
thing that this new one world you know
post-modern world is is growing and
developing and we view that as a bad
thing it's interesting uh history will
tell you know the it's written by The
Victors and we'll see I think based on
what we've seen over the past couple of
years though somebody posted a there's a
Bible tweet I'm sorry I can't remember
remember who posted it but they were
like it's time to stop being black
pilled we're winning and they posted all
of these things that happened in the
past like two months that are tremendous
victories for Liberty personal
responsibility meritocracy Elon Musk is
a great example five years after Carl
Benjamin was banned he's back it's crazy
I'm like Carl is uh one of the first
culture Warriors in the culture War
and it's interesting if if back when he
started making content calling out
Academia and intersectional feminism
immediately political leaders were like
we identify what he's saying and it's a
problem
it would have stopped in its tracks and
we'd be in a very very different future
10 years on
now what are we seeing five years after
he's banned his back Elon musk's moves
are all greatly beneficial to the causes
of Liberty and uh meritocracy and a
bunch of other things mind you it's not
just those you know core principles or
core uh ideologies or whatever or
whatever you want to call them it's uh a
lot of Victory happening so I think
looking at way think the way things are
going now especially with abortion for
instance
the end result is obvious
one side is consistently saying have
kids have kids have kids the other side
is saying we reserve the right not to
and I tweeted this I tweeted Democrats
are arguing for the right not to have
children or grandchildren and it was
funny because the left thought that I
was saying they shouldn't have that
right no that's what they're I'm like
I'm explaining this is what they want
Why argue against them okay
then don't have kids
see ya in 20 years our kids will inherit
the earth that's just the reality and
it's not meant to be disrespectful it's
just the truth yeah the history is
actually completely on our side because
any time in the 20th century for example
that these people got a little bit too
out of hand started being really radical
being communist there is always that
sort of right-wing government that comes
in and gets things more or less under
control and that's what they're afraid
of and also we are like normal people we
are the stock of people that build
civilizations that builds countries
these people these wannabe leftist
revolutionaries the antifa larpers these
are people who are like fundamentally
like in despair they can't even make eye
contact with Baristas when they order a
coffee these people are not gonna like
run the country they're not going to run
the government even the people running
it now are far less intelligent and far
less competent than the people who
ushered in the sort of totalitarianism
that we have now I've been thinking that
you know like uh we had we had a um who
said this the other day that since
Epstein died everything's been falling
apart there's a funny point I'm like
that is a that's a weird thing and how
about that but I was thinking about you
know I remember George H.W bush saying
something like we can now begin to see a
new world order and it's a reference to
the liberal economic order that was
created after World War II we've talked
about Ad nauseam the CFR has it on their
website they talk all about it they're
News Guard certified by the way and
that's an old system they want a new
system and I thought about how is
everything falling apart how did Donald
Trump win and I'm like oh I get it the
children of these people are inept and
it's obvious they say that wealth lasts
three generations someone who is hard
working builds it has kids who did not
work hard who inherit it who have who
have children themselves the grandkids
who have no idea how to even manage the
money because they weren't taught by
their grandfather and then the money
evaporates yeah the same is true for
those that run the government it's like
three generations on and that ability to
control the system is lost to them yeah
and you're seeing as things continue to
decline all of these people just emerge
from the woodwork you know Donald Trump
we love him Blake Masters Kerry Lake all
these people who previously were not
known to Republicans or conservatives
they're all like rising to the occasion
and they're very talented they're great
candidates they're good on the issues
and it almost recalls like the founding
I mean I was talking with your driver on
the way over about George Washington
they had to beg this guy to come lead
the army they had to beg him to come be
the president he was just like a wealthy
aristocratic Farmer they had to beg him
and now he's like one of the greatest
America probably the greatest American
of all time and you're going to see that
ad thing as things continue to decline
you're going to have Americans who still
exist I mean there are tens of millions
of us they're going to be like you know
what I'm a very smart guy I've been very
successful in whatever practice I've
chosen to pursue but now is my time and
they're going to get involved in
politics and they are going to perform
better than the people we have now
they're going to be far more popular and
I think that ultimately we will make
America great again things will also
play themselves out you know a lot of
the people who are chemically castrated
whether by choice or by you know
circumstance of everything else around
us that was instituted by the state
they're not going to be having children
the people who are going to be having
children other people who still believe
in families still believe in marriages
still hopefully believe in in having a
future for this country and those are
the people that are going to be the
Future Leaders of this country so I have
hope in that particular aspect but then
I also see a lot of the bigger problems
and this is again why I'm so kind of
allergic to people calling for more
State intervention because just like the
state could be used for for you know
some people's ideas of good it could
also be used for bad but when you have a
bigger State you have the the
possibility of that pendulum swinging
back even harder yeah I agree with that
in terms of the size of the state if
we're going to measure in like dollars
which I think is a pretty fair metric in
my ideal government you know it would be
like one tenth the size I mean there's
so much waste so much patronize or
patronage rewarding friend things like
that so much way so the actual size of
my government in terms of like how big
it is in money it would be significantly
smaller in terms of How It's actually
like a affecting your day-to-day life
also would be significantly smaller
unless you're like a groomer or a
communist or something like that but
you're not you're very fine people
you'll be fine but this actually does
vindicate your point earlier too about
the alternative alternative school
choices because leftists don't reproduce
by having kids leftists reproduced by
grooming kids so they in they infiltrate
whether it's like Early Education or
then even on social media now and they
try to poison children's Minds into
buying into all this Ridiculousness and
these poor conservative parents they
actually believed perhaps naively but we
understand it they could still send
their kids to schools and they wouldn't
become indoctrinated and now you've got
these poor dads having to like argue
with their children about why they don't
actually own their minds and why because
you know if it's not the parents that
own the minds of the child it's going to
be the state as you mentioned this is
crazy to me we've had people come here
to the studio and be like passively
we're talking they'll be like oh yeah
you know my kids they're gonna be home
from college for the holiday and I'm
like what do you not listen to your own
commentary like how do you have kids in
college well they'll be fine though I
disagree there are good schools out
there I went to them
like I know I mean Christendom college
is one of them name five University is
Stephenville
five I'm kidding I'm kidding no I I
disagree uh I think they're all bad I
think they're just they're good Catholic
schools out there I don't know about the
rest but I I know that there are bright
spots fair point I suppose uh then to
clarify I'm talking about people who are
saying that their kids are going to like
state universities and things like that
and I'm just like kind of shocked that
they would come and be alive look what's
happening to these kids and I'm like bro
you're putting yourself a lot of them
say like oh my kid is influencing the
the students around them they're the
influence they're a good good influence
on the students around them and that's
completely delusional didn't Jim Breuer
do a bit about this for stand up that
went viral where he was like my daughter
came back from college and was calling
me like an evil white man or something
like that I I believe that I didn't see
it probably how insane yeah did you see
the the black supremacist that was
speaking out against her father during
the father's funeral yes that was
disgusting that was shocking and that
was terrifying to see the indoctrination
where you know a child who was raised by
a father that pretty much gave her
everything gave her an Ivy League
education spent millions of dollars into
making sure that she got the best
education that education turned to her
during the funeral denouncing and
calling out the father as a bigot and a
horrible human being and that's like the
restructuring of values where now the
dopamine that she got from that is worth
more to her than loyalty to her family
and we saw this too during the summer of
love these poor dads in like Middle
America were getting exposed and
canceled on Tick Tock by their stupid
daughters being like he didn't post a
black Square he's watching Fox News he's
racist and they're just like what where
did I go wrong I feel so badly for those
men the dopamine from social media
interactions that have an algorithm that
prioritizes this that incentivizes this
that I personally believe is controlled
by the government especially the DHS
that has a hand in what people see and
what they don't see and I think this is
all being done deliberately in my own
personal opinion for my own assertions
John you said feel badly for those men
but it's like oh completely they've kind
of wedded their daughters to the world
in a way that I I can't I can't
sympathize completely you gave them a
smartphone at 12 years old you sent them
to public schools and you didn't instill
religious values in them or tell them
that they're beautiful it's like what
what do you expect to happen I agree
with that but I mean imagine like how
children were being raised in like the
1920s 1930s you know the boomer
generation really was the first
generation to be like psyopt by
television into rebelling from their
parents I mean this whole idea of like
oh they're a teenager they're rebelling
from the prince that is very
historically new it is something that
was really invented in the 20th century
because like you mentioned they have an
incentive to use technology to get into
the minds of the youth and program them
how they will I feel bad in the sense
that I really firmly believe that
American men men in the world should be
able to not have to worry about if my
child goes to the same school as all
these other people if they do this I
think they should still be proactive in
their child's lives but I do think it's
very sad how now they have to dedicate
so much much time that their fathers and
grandfathers would not have had to
dedicate to making sure that their child
doesn't end up hating them and
denouncing them at their funeral
homeschool your kids yeah that's that
you know uh
become good at things read more develop
a skill have a family homeschool your
kids all of that stuff and uh
that's that's the that's the first thing
you know clean up your own room before
you try to change the world but then we
focus on the ballot harvesting problem
then we focus on the uh the neocon you
know and the establishment problem and
we just try to make everything gradually
better every day you will take a single
step and before you realize you'll have
walked A Thousand Miles thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time